un nuevo reto en la lucha contra el
coronavirus pzifer y variante que
empezaron a probar la eficacia de sus
respectivas vacunas frente a la nueva
cepa de coronavirus hallada en reino
unido
que estamos seguros de que será el caso
ya que en el pasado hemos probado más de
20 variantes de virus con diferentes
tipos de mutaciones y el resultado
siempre fue que la vacuna indujo la
respuesta inmune que es tan amplia que
ataca múltiples posiciones en esta
proteína del virus y sólo tiene que
calcular el 99 por ciento de esta
proteína
colette de atlántida presentar test por
spotify ser se declaró optimista pero
aclaró que podría rediseñar su vacuna en
seis semanas en caso de que no funcione
y en un intento de dar confianza a los
ciudadanos algunos de los principales
funcionarios de atención médica de eeuu
fueron inoculados con una primera dosis
de la vacuna contra el cob y 19 de la
multinacional moderna
es tan importante o más importante que
es un símbolo para todo el país que
siente una confianza extrema en la
seguridad y eficacia de estado
una y quiero animar a todos los que
tienen la oportunidad de vacunarse para
que podamos tener un vuelo de protección
sobre este país que acabaría esta
pandemia
el llamado de los funcionarios se da en
medio de una campaña para incentivar la
vacunación masiva en eeuu y en medio del
aumento de la desconfianza en parte de
la población respecto a recibir fármacos
desarrollados en tiempo récord